there's this page on leech assets.org
opening
another day I searched for Eric I was
curious if there's any openings named
after Eric
and then the openings that came up were
the Frederico and then a few openings
with the phrase American I discovered
it's um it's just searching for the
string Eric so any any word that
contains the string will show up so it
turns out there's three openings
that have the term American in it
there's a nimso American variation In
the Sicilian
there's a stone Gambit American attack
and there is the American attack against
uh Sicilian taimala
so I made the study
on nichas
with these three openings
and I thought I would show them and then
try and get some games in them maybe in
title Tuesday maybe against viewers
let's start with the most dubious one
which is
the American attack against the Dutch
and I did some brief analysis earlier
but I really haven't dug in like so
deeply to these openings so I think I'll
give an overview of all three and then
I'll try and get some games in them
uh so the American attack against the
Dutch of course we start with D4 F5
and then it comes from a strong Gambit
E4
almost everyone takes
now the main move by far is Knight C3
at least in Master Level play
actually the American attack has never
been played in Master Level play
um but the American attack is not Knight
C3 it's Knight T2
and it's just kind of a dubious opening
embodying the culture of American fast
food
very dubious to consume too much of
but uh it's interesting at least white
hits the pawn most people will play
either Knight F6 or D5 at least on
leechas
and then the idea is to play F3
and get some kind of
uh maybe BlackMart dimmer type Gambit
where if black takes which most people
do then takes
and I I was analyzing this earlier that
if black like plays a setup let's say E6
Bishop D3 white can castle and then
potentially go for a queen side attack
it actually looks like somewhat playable
um the engine doesn't like it you turn
on engine here it says like minus 0.6
uh it says Knight F6
and then after F3 D5
but I was analyzing this too and here
this move C3 which is the top engine
move I actually like because it's very
flexible enables Queen B3
and again like most people do end up
taking and then takes and then it's a
game there's also a line like black can
play E3 here
just shoving the pawn very far and down
but then after Knight's C4 liken
probably just went back upon or d595
even
and then White's gonna achieve some nice
kind of freedom and liberty with the
pieces
so the goal is to make make your pieces
free I guess
in honor of America
so moving on to the second one
American attack against the Sicilian
this is probably the most sound out of
the three different American variations
but it's also a little bit questionable
it begins with an open Sicilian happy
Fourth of July happy Fourth of July yeah
trying to stay true to today's theme
so this variation happens within the
four nights in E6
so far this is just called the Four
Knights variation
your boy Logie bear says
streamer it's your turn for my rotating
sub once again oh hello Raku
what does your boy Louie Bear say
freedom freedom if you can't leave them
be them
it's the fourth of July we shall lie on
the grass out back
to expose our eyes to explosions in the
sky
eventually we'll get to the fireworks
we might see some fireworks from this
opening though
so the main move here is Knight DB5
and okay black has two main moves but
against Bishop B4
white can play the American attack
and let's check Master Level or Master's
database
okay the American attack has been played
26 times in the Masters database
96.
and at first this looks really good
but after King E7 black actually is okay
here because Knight's attacked and if we
take the bishop
then Lock's just a hidden development
and we just spent one two three four
five moves
just to trade off our Knight for a
bishop that didn't move
and like even though it has a bishop
hair black will
um will be fine engine slightly prefers
black
so I thought if White's gonna play the
American attack
we don't want to just
surrender our Knights we want to attack
or at least defend first so the move to
play here is Bishop F4 defending the
Knight
and then later we can attack because the
main move is E5
and rather than moving the bishop we
counter attack
and then after King f8s the engine is a
little bit confused it just says it's
equal happy Independence Day Eric happy
Independence Day amen
so after Bishop D2 it's just kind of a
wild position
and there's only been like three games
but White's never lost in Master Level
play
on leechas
Bach actually scores pretty well
but I was analyzing D5 earlier
after D5 white can take
and essentially offer the trade of
knights and most people take on a five
and after he takes
Bishop C4
the engine already prefers White
so this would be like maybe viable a
viable opening to prepare and even a
higher level
of course there's a lot of branches
like there is
I mean there's Bishop takes C3 first
and then
if we take with Bishop then D5 there's
also a knight takes E4
this could get really crazy like Queen
G4 this is where we see the fireworks
where's my fireworks
here's my fireworks
okay
took some time at the beginning of the
stream to make this happen
anyway
that's the American attack against the
Sicilian
mulhas says why not Bishop D6 after
Knight D6
oh yeah Bishop takes D6 we're very happy
like takes takes
and black just surrendered the darks for
Bishop and most of the pawns are on
light squares so we're just going to be
dominating these dark squares and this
Bishop's really sad
the engine should give wow already plus
two for White Knight B5 is maybe coming
yeah there's a big headache for black
it's that headache that you get when you
um
you can't sleep at night because there's
so many fireworks even before the 4th of
July like the last few days there's just
been fireworks non-stop late at night
what to do
okay so the final American variation
the final one is probably the one I'm
most excited about it's also one I'm
most likely to play in title Tuesday
because it comes from a A variation
I play at least the first few moves of
and I wasn't aware of the existence of
this line until maybe earlier today when
I actually started looking into it
so the American variation or this is
called the nimso American variation of
the Sicilian
it starts as an open Sicilian with
Knight C6
and after D4 takes takes
the move to make it the nimso American
variation
is one two three four five six seven
eight nine it's the tenth most popular
move on michas
and Masters database was also pretty
rare
played zero percent of the time
more like zero point something percent
of the time
but the move is D5
and this is also dubious
but it's interesting like it's it's a
move that I think a lot of players just
won't be prepared for
and we fight for the center
I was doing a bit of preparation earlier
like the two most common moves people
will play maybe there's three most
common moves there's Knight takes C6
which I think is fine for black they
just take back what's the point here ed5
oh can we not take because Bishop B5
yeah we'd have to take with Queen
but this is playable
especially if white takes and my box
completely fine here
so the other two moves are Bishop B5 and
pawn takes Pawn
and with Bishop E5 there's a cool
variation where we ignore this Knight
hey it's just Dojo what's up chest dojo
if you're just joining I'm showing chess
openings named for
America
and I'm showing now the the nimzo
American variation and well it's just
about to show after Bishop B5
White's attacking the Knight twice
we don't defend we just take the pawn
and the point is when white takes on C6
we first trade Queens
and of course we can't take back because
[Music]
uh then we got forked we can't play
Bishop D7 either because Knight D4
defends a bishop but we have the move
here A6
and this is playable like the Bishops
now attacked Knight's still attacked
and after Bishop A4 we have Bishop D7
and black is winning back the piece
and I did some pretty deep analysis
based on the most common line because
most players will play Knight C3
black can take take take take so it's a
big trade it's now equal material and
then there's this move F5
and then we just want to like expand
control more territory maybe just like
the American government Maybe
and
yeah this is um it's actually Pleasant
for black engine will maybe say white
slightly better but after King E2
flight's not really threatening to take
because rookie Eights so we complain
that six first and then if takes rookie
eight let's say F4 and Bishop D6 we're
gonna win back upon with more activity
so anyway that's like a real quick
synopsis of these three American
openings
and my goal today is to play
at least one of them entitled Tuesday
a few more seconds
okay
so here is how it's gonna work we're
gonna play into the Sicilian American
attack
but let's send a challenge
here we go
okay so I need everyone to cooperate if
you don't cooperate you might get banned
or at least timed out
I do request that chat play into the
Sicilian Defense so C5 here all you need
to do is type C5
in chat
there we go okay
got some got some Chatters now
hopefully this works
as a moment of truth
not sure how long it takes every move
is it not working oh it's working let's
go
and then Knight C6
or E6 it actually doesn't matter
let's see which move is more popular
one vote for H5
to find that one person and ban them for
the rest of time
the 75 votes nice okay so now this move
you know what to do take the pawns he
takes D4
I think you have to write
c x D4
can I vote myself to
oh I can't well I could maybe
mess mess up my opponent here
this is unrated okay so now uh Knight F6
it's gonna be a fortnight Sicilian
E6 is also playable E6 could transpose
okay now Knight C3 now E6
so what do we call this like taimanov
some variation of time on of
fortnite Sicilian
we're almost getting to the American
attack
get ready for it I actually don't know
like the the history or the origin of
why it's called the American attack
but now Knight B5
and now Bishop B4
is
um it's still Theory like this this move
has been played at like top GM level
I'm going to type Bishop B4 myself
okay most people are following into this
which I I do appreciate
and now the next move
makes the opening the American attack
Knight D6 check
and I showed this earlier
but now I'm not gonna tell
I'm not going to tell what black should
play here because now it's a fight this
is where chat
can be let loose
and
try and figure out the position for
yourself
I think a lot of people maybe remember
the move I showed earlier or
already maybe have a sense of what the
best move is
King E7 good job Chad this is the best
move
uh it's a basically a four spawn clown
now Bishop F4
and I only studied this like briefly
before the Stream
but let's see how people do
I'm gonna try and like destroy
black as quickly as possible
to destroy the however many hundreds or
a thousand people who are watching and
participating
okay now Nyla five
have fun deciding where your king should
go
King E6 would be hilarious
but probably not recommended
a few people voting for King E6
King f8 could move
now Bishop G5 so this is still prep on
my parts
only four votes for King musics
so I got some fireworks actually I don't
have the fireworks in this scene I have
confetti though
not sure if this position calls for
confetti just yet
the premature confetti H6
H6 was actually like a reasonable
looking move
if I take
wait a minute now I have to think
maybe this and then
G5 there there
okay let's be careful
I have to be really careful here
can I flip the board
I feel like if I were to flip the board
I should have done so earlier
but also we're looking from the American
perspective
so
I'm sorry
next time I play shadow I'll have the
boy from chess perspective
oh yeah you could like watch
uh as an observer
seven people are watching here
D6 not a bad move
all right let's play Bishop C4
yeah it's a really sharp position like
blocks lost casting rights but Knight is
maybe a Target on that five
oh yeah Chad is America's opposition
earlier during title Tuesday
someone was saying that I need to
destroy the English opening
in honor of the Fourth of July
turn the pieces of red white and blue
theme is there an American theme
what is this one
I could really mess with people here
uh we have the horsey
okay there's a B3 probably actually I
don't like my position here
I'll change it back to normal or I mean
this is the closest we can get to
American colors
oh yes my diaper
and my pear and my gangsta Knight
all right let's go back to normal
um
man I played the American attack and now
I feel like it's America getting
attacked
what is this
look at these Pawns at least my Bishop
is Happy kind of
these Bishops might be traded soon
I'm realizing I'm gonna have to go in
about
10 to 15 minutes
I have plans in the real world
this game should be over by then I think
okay we're we're definitely in the
middle game now
although I still haven't castled
holding off on castling
it's cool to see the variety of moves
one person wanted King g8s
previous position
[Music]
okay it's time to attack
and be a Patriots
four H4
I guess all of Chad is basically stream
sniping me right now
but I can reverse stream tonight chat
chat see what moves are likely to come
H5 may be coming wow
wow
preventing G4
all right always always play off three
now let's Castle queenside
this is gonna be super Sharp
like I want to attack here
some people want to attack on the queen
side
don't hurt me too much though
there is a very strong move for black
which
I should say thank you for not playing
Knight E4 I think would have been
crushing hitting this and this
so let's play F3 now
Rook C8 was a fine move
King is on the half open file
[Music]
I like F3 though preventing Knight E4 I
want to play G4
good luck stopping G4 now
wow a lot of people wanting to play H4
wow it's not if I play G4 there's on
poisson
very clever
all right let's play G4 anyway
I wonder how many people are gonna type
on person in chats
not understanding notation
or maybe just
mimicking me
okay let's pre-move this
yeah it's still really sharp each file
is open now
I don't think
um
black is capable of stopping G4 now
it was a valiant effort to play H5 H4
but
good luck
obese says D4
I think illegal moves
probably won't be accepted
Rook H2 okay kind of scary
it would be cool if um
if this bot could have a reading
like the collective nature of twitch
chat and so far I guess ELO is like
maybe around 1900 to 2000
playing sensible moves
wow
that move was unexpected
how do I punish it
I really want to punish that move
I play Queen G5
I think maybe I just played G4
actually I'm gonna start with Rook h8
as a nice gift Rook comes in there's one
legal move
only eight people voted for rogue G2 it
narrowly edges out Rook H1
so 98's only legal move I'm gonna follow
up with
maybe probably G4 although maybe Rook H1
play Rook H1
yeah difficult position for black
the American attack seems to be working
a lot of different moves being suggested
now
I don't know what oh F6
uh I feel like a disappointed teacher
like I've
I've always praised connect for
and
um and always play off six
one person says we won GG chats
oh I feel so bad but no mercy
okay
happy birthday America
if this goes on YouTube
if this goes on YouTube I'd better like
end the stream download the VOD and edit
the video and Export it and upload and
post it before midnight
but happy July 4th can we get some
confetti
maybe some fireworks later
if you ban everyone who suggests bad
moves chat could win
that's actually a great idea
that's like
evolution
natural selection
Darwinism I'll save the idea for the
future